معنى مدير المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان
رامي عبد الرحمن للحديث اكثر عن تداعيات
هذا الزلزال استاذ رامي سابدا بالسؤال على
المناطق السوريه الخاضعه لسيطره النظام
بما اننا ننقل الواقع بالمناطق الاخرى منذ
بدايه هذه الفتره الاخباريه كيف هو الواقع
هناك كيف يتم توزيع المساعدات وهناك
العديد من المساعدات التي وصلت الى سوريا
مشروطه بان يتم توزيعه لكامل السوريين
بدون تمييز بين المناطق التي مع النظام
والمناطق التي تدل نظام كيف هي الصوره
بهذا الموضوع
نعم مساء الخير بدون تمييز ولكن التمييز
واضح حقيقه الامر ودون تحيز لان الواقع
لان 86 طائره وصلت الى مناطق النظام حتى
تاريخه من دول عربيه عده من دول غير عربيه
كان من المفترض ان توزع على كامل ابناء
الشعب السوري عندما نرى البعد الوضع
الماساوي في شمال غرب سوريا والمساعدات
الشحيحه التي تصل الى تلك المنطقه بينما
نرى تدفق للمساعدات الى مناطق النظام دون
ان تصل الى تلك المنطقه هذه لا يوجد عداله
بالتوزيع ولكن نعود الى مناطق النظام هل
المساعدات وزعت بشكل حقيقي على مستحقيها
بشكل قطع لو كانت المساعدات منزعت بشكل
حقيقي على مستحقيها لما شاهدنا بان
استمرار الحملات الاهليه السوريه بشكل
مكثف من كامل المناطق السوريه تتجه باتجاه
حلب باتجاه اللاذقيه باتجاه حماه باتجاه
ريف اللاذقيه لم يتجه اليه شيء مثل ما
سابقا هناك الكثير من القرى يوجد فيها
منازل مقدمه يوجد فيها مشردين لم تصل
اليها جماعه النظام او قوات النظام الذين
يتولون توزيع المساعدات هنا الكارثه حزب
البعث العربي الاشتراكي يتولى توزيع
المساعدات في بعض المناطق راينا في حلب
ميليشيات ايران تقوم بتوزيع المساعدات
يعني يعني ايران هل هي جزء من الاراضي
السوريه نعود نقول لا نريد الحديث في
السياسه ولكن تفرض علينا الواقع بان هناك
ان نبتعد عن السياسه لان الواقع الذي
ننقله اليوم وقع انساني بحث ولكن يعني خلط
السياسه بالانساني هو بمعظم الازمات يتم
استخدامه للاسف ساسالك رامي عن الاعداد هل
هناك اي حصيله رسميه صدرت من هذه المناطق
حول المفقودين حول الناجين حول يعني الناس
الذين لم يستطيعوا ان ينجوا من هذا
الزلزال
يعني بالنسبه للنظام هناك في قرى ذكرناها
سابقا 21 قريه لم تصل الى قوات النظام ولا
تدخلها في احصائياتها وكان فيها المئات من
السوريين قتلوا ودفنوا في مناطقهم ووصلت
اليها بعد اربعه او خمسه ايام وهي قرى شرق
ادلب وريف حلب الجنوبي بالنسبه للاحصائيات
في مناطق النظام الى الان النظام يتحدث عن
1500 1600 الاحصائيات التي لدينا من
المناطق التي
في النظام 278 على الاقل هؤلاء المؤكدين
هناك مفقودين في مباني يعني فرق الانقاذ
انهت عملها في حلب لكن هناك مباني لا تزال
هدمت بالسنسال لا يعلم هل كان حقيقه الامر
لا يوجد فيها احد ام كان يوجد فيها احد
ولا احد يعلم من يسكن في تلك المناطق
لماذا انهت قوات النظام او انهت الفرق
الانقاذ عملها هناك فرق انقاذ غادرت من
الجزائر وارمينيا والاردن انهت عملها
وغادرت دون ان يكون هناك انتشار يعني من
هم على قيد الحياه
الجسامين الوضع كارثي بكل معنى الكلمه
والنظام لم يرتقي لحسن المسؤوليه في هذه
هل لدى المرصد اي عدد تقريبي يعني بعموم
المناطق ليس فقط المناطق الخاضعه على
النظام
هل لديك نعم
نعم نعم في عموم المناطق المؤكدين لديناهم
5329 بشكل قطعي لكن هناك مفقودين العدد
عقد المفقودين حتى اللحظه يبلغ نحو 2000
شخص سواء في مناطق النظام او مناطق
المعارضه لان مثل ما شاهدنا جنديرس نشرتهم
على العربيه والحدث كيف هي منطقه دمرت
بشكل كبير جدا ارتفاع المدني قال بانه عمل
في 14 مبنى بينما المباني المدمره بشكل
كامل هي اكثر من 84 مبدا يوجد مفقودين في
كامل المناطق السوريه مناطق النظام ومناطق
المعارضه العدد قد يرتفع الى 7000 لكن
قضيه المفقودين لا نستطيع
الجن ب
ان هناك ولا احد يعلم اين هم بطبيعه الحال
يعني عندما نتحدث عن دوله مشتته ومفككه
يعني لا يكون هناك ارقام رسميه كامله ولكن
نحن نتحدث عن الارقام التقديريه شكرا لك
رامي عبد الرحمن من المركز والمرصد السوري
لحقوق الانسان